وانوه الى الخبر العاجل مراسله الجزيره
تفيد بوقوع قصف مدفعي اسرائيليا لمواقع
مختلفه في حي الشجاعيه والاطراف الشرقيه
لمدينه غزه وقد افاد مراسل الجزيره ايضا
باستشهاد شاب فلسطيني واصابه اخرين في قصف
اسرائيلي استهدف منازل المواطنين في مخيم
المغازي وسط قطاع غزه يذكر ان الطائرات
الحربيه والمدفعيه اغارت فجر اليوم على
مخيمي المغازي والبر وسط اشتباكات عنيفه
مع المقاومه الفلسطينيه خاصه في محور مخيم
البريج كما دمرت الطائرات مسجدين في مدينه
دير البلح ومخيم المغازي وسط
[موسيقى]
القطع وشيع اهالي قطاع غزه من مستشفى
شهداء الاقصى في دير البلح عشرات الشهداء
الذين سقطوا في قصف اسرائيلي واستهدف هذا
القصف منازل المواطنين مساء امس وفجر
اليوم في المنطقه الوسطى من قطاع غزه
وشهدت المنطقه الوسطى خلال ال4 ساعه
الماضيه استشهاد 64 فلسطينيا واصابه
186 في القصف
الاسرائيلي